well let's talk about that with our next
guest the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons thank you very much for
being on the programme
thank you for listening across the
report that we just did too
um how concerned are you about the rise
in
children and young people being
exploited during the pandemic
it's a deep concern and just listening
then to alicia in that report
really did bring home to me firstly
the increasing number of county lines
things gone by
near 300 percent over the last decade
but also
during the pandemic as that report
brought out
it's clear that the profile of people
who have been drawn in are getting
younger
and more and more young women and girls
getting drawn in
as well now what we need to see it seems
to me are two major things
i think firstly we need to see strategic
leadership on this issue at the home
office i think it was a grave error
to abolish the serious violence task
force which was announced to great
fanfare
because often county lines are
associated with other types of crime
including gang violence
but secondly we need to be doing all we
can
to give these young people who are
getting drawn into county lines
the opportunity to make a very different
life and we see that for example
in london where the mayor of london has
introduced a
rescue and recovery fund to actually
invest to try and ensure
that people get the help they need this
is an awful crime it's exploiting young
people
and it really should be a top priority
now to try and do all we can to deal
with it
now staying on policy and crime you of
course are publishing labor's
a plan to tackle violent crime and help
support victims
what's the idea
well look firstly i think we have to
realize the scale
of the problem violent crime has gone up
in
every single police force area of
england and wales over the last
decade in four out of five areas it
has doubled and there are now 200
violent crimes happening every hour this
is a
chronic failure frankly under this
conservative government
violent criminals have never had it so
good and we've got
to tackle that so what do we need to do
and what am i suggesting
today well we need more police
out there on the streets not behind
desks
we need to make sure that we change our
approach to preventative services not
see them decimated as we have
over the last decade we need tougher
sentences for example
for rape and we need in my view now to
have a
victim's law victim should be at the
heart of our criminal
justice system and that's why i think we
actually need to put that
into law so there's a victim's law that
puts victims first
you know i've listened to what you said
and i sort of read into a bit of what
you're proposing as well and of course
the rise in violent crime is something
that everyone will be very concerned by
but i can't help thinking that some of
the ideas sound very good on paper but
actually things are a lot more
complicated than that i mean the first
thing you said for example is
insuring more police on the beat rather
than behind desks
but if violent crime cases have doubled
charging rates
have fallen down 22 percent in 2014-15
to 6.8
in 2019-20 it feels to me like the
problem
is actually convincing the crown
prosecution
service to take these cases forward it's
about building the case work i mean
that's often done from behind a desk
isn't it doesn't sound quite as
you know appealing as getting more
bobbies on the beat but that's a reality
isn't it
well no no it is a systemic failure and
the point that is made there about
charging rates is absolutely right as
well but that is
a failure right through the criminal
justice system from this government
which has
obviously cut the budget of the ministry
of justice by an extraordinary amount
since 2010 but my point is this you have
to have systemic
change right from the start so
we we took it took many years for the
government to admit that falling police
numbers were actually related to the
rise in violent crime and that's why now
we've got to focus on
visible policing community policing
which has suffered
so much over the past 11 years so that
that acts both as a
lincoln the eyes and ears of the local
community
but also assisting in terms of detecting
crime
but you're absolutely right to say that
this goes right through
the system and that's why i've suggested
the other things that i have
around crime prevention preventing
people from becoming victims of crime in
the first place
but then looking at it right through the
system and that's why
putting victims first is so so important
and that's why i believe
we now need to have legal duties to
ensure that victims get the support they
need
from start to finish in the criminal
justice system that doesn't just mean at
the end of the trial by the way because
just because a trial has ended
doesn't end the trauma for the victim we
also need to see a system whereby
victims are kept informed and have that
information support they need
post-trial as well talking about victims
you know the second
thing that you said you wanted to do was
tougher sentences for rape
the maximum sentence for rape is life
imprisonment and the problem
again is about getting those convictions
in the first place so in the year to
march 2020
1.4 of rape cases recorded by police
resulted in a suspect
being charged that's a real problem
tackling it isn't about getting more
bobbies on the beat it isn't about you
know easy wins on
getting parliament to vote through
tougher sentences
it's the difficult painstaking work in
getting
those convictions in the first place
isn't it
it absolutely is and i find this debate
so frustrating because
why are you just proposing these easy
wins then rather than
tackling the big problems
no i'm not we're not we've published a
uh
a support plan for rape survivors in
recent weeks in addition
to the measures that i've announced
today and you're absolutely right
because
99 of every 100 reported
rapes doesn't even reach legal
proceedings
let alone a conviction and what we need
to be putting in place
is that support for rape victims at the
very start secondly we need to be fast
tracking rape and serious sexual
violence cases through the system so
people aren't waiting
months and months in sometimes some
cases years for justice
but we also need and we've argued this
in recent weeks a specific minister with
responsibility for this
with responsibility for rape and serious
sexual violence for precisely the reason
sophie that you've just said so that you
can drive change
right through the system and that's
absolutely what we require in addition
to raising that minimum sentence for
rate which is currently at five years
but absolutely it is
changed through the system that we need
and i'm so frustrated
because i've asked for this for the last
five years and the situation is simply
getting worse okay i'm keen to
ask you about the protest that we've
seen this week outside at batley grammar
school this is after a teacher
showed an offensive cartoon of the
prophet muhammed the schools
apologized suspended the teacher who's
now under police protection
should teachers be allowed to show
cartoons of the prophet muhammad
well look in in this particular case i
think we just need
to lower tensions firstly
the school has actually taken action as
you've mentioned
in relation to this which i think was
the right thing to do but what we've now
got to do
moving forward is absolutely to be
putting
children learners first lowering those
tensions now
and actually moving forward i think that
is what is absolutely
essential now because to continue
to to raise tensions in this situation
certainly isn't going to assist anybody
at least the
least alone those people who absolutely
should be coming first who are those who
are learning
at that school in battley but you think
suspending the teacher was the right
thing to do
look i i think the school has acted that
has now
obviously taken place that action has
happened i think what now needs to
happen as i say
is we need to lower the tension and we
need now
to actually move on putting the children
first we can't have either
any situations where teachers or others
are somehow intimidated trying to go
about their work that is something
that's not acceptable what we have to do
is to move on now and ensure that the
children have that learning particularly
at the moment when you consider
all the disruption there's been to young
people's education over the past 12
months that absolutely has to come first
okay and we have been talking about
scotland a lot on the program after alex
salmond
set up this new party in scotland
which is going to be contesting the list
seats in the election
um ken mccaskill said it's all about
trying to build a super majority for
independence
we've heard from douglas ross the leader
of the scottish conservatives who says
he wants to effectively build a super
majority for the union labour is saying
no though why not
why not well because labour is putting
forward
its own strong arguments at this
election i mean what i see are the
nationalists splitting
obsessed with the constitutional
question the
conservatives simply seem to want to
play politics with the union it's the
labour party in scotland or
andhra sawah who is making absolutely
clear
the focus now has to be on the recovery
from the coronavirus i think quite
rightly that's what people
not just in scotland but people right
across the united kingdom
should expect of political parties we've
had this huge national crisis
with the coronavirus now is the point to
actually get that recovery
plan in place anasawa has spoken very
powerfully about that
whether it's around education and the
catch-up that's required whether it's
around our national health service
and the nhs in scotland and all the work
that needs to be done
on non-coronavirus cases our community
recovery
that's the case that we are putting
forward
to the people of scotland anas is making
that case very powerfully
and of course i will support them in any
way i can in doing that
and just quickly uncovered we also heard
from oliver dowd and of course the
culture secretary and we were discussing
the idea of this
traffic light system for foreign travel
and amber light for example meaning you
just have to quarantine for a short
period with enhanced testing
is that something the labour would
support
well look if that is put forward in due
course i'll of course look at it and
consider it in the light of the
circumstances of the time
but the priority at the moment is the
gaping hole in our defenses
at the border and closing that we have a
situation where we've got
vaccine rollout and great credit to
those of the front line doing that
and the sacrifices the british people
have made over the past 12 months
and yet we do not have that
comprehensive
hotel quarantining system in place at
our borders i think only about one
percent of arrivals at the moment
are actually being put in hotel
quarantine now that has to change i've
argued that for
weeks and weeks and the reason i argue
it
is because we do not want to see a
variant of the
virus reaching our shores that threatens
the efficacy of our vaccines
we have to do everything we possibly can
to stop that
and that should be the priority at the
moment in the form of a hotel
uh quarantining system that's
comprehensive
just finally reports on the papers today
that annelise dodds
could lose her position as shadow
chancellor and be sacked in a reshuffle
are you a little bit relieved you've
been put up for the morning round this
morning perhaps
saying or might be safe in your position
i don't take any notice of the gossip
and the speculation that appears in the
newspapers around this it's something
that
part of political life anna lisa dodds
i've been working with over the past uh
12 months
is doing an excellent job and as a very
strong team
led by kiyosama we are we are the ones
who are putting forward the very clear
choice of this election
of a labour party that's on the side of
communities recovering from the
coronavirus
around the country in contrast to i'm
afraid a conservative party that just
wants to take this country back to the
past
a politician not interested in reshuffle
speculation that must be a first
nick thomas simmons thank you very much
for being on the program